مع قيام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بأول زيارة له لاحتلال أوكرانيا
منذ بدء الحرب ، انظروا هذا
فيديو له وهو يقود سيارته عبر مدينة
مارويبول التي احتلتها روسيا العام الماضي ،
وتعرضت المدينة لأضرار جسيمة
ومعارك وأصبحت رمزًا
لمقاومة أوكرانيا
عدوان موسكو ، يقول الكرملين إن بوتين
توقف أيضًا في منطقتهم وتحدث
إلى السكان الذين قالوا إنه تمت دعوته
إلى أحد منازلهم في وقت مبكر يوم
السبت ، حيث سافر بوتين إلى شبه جزيرة القرم للاحتفال
بالذكرى التاسعة منذ
إعلان روسيا ضم
شبه الجزيرة الأوكرانية.
بعد أن أرسلت روسيا قواتها وأجرت
استفتاءًا سريعًا في عام 2014. وتقول أوكرانيا إن
شبه جزيرة القرم تعاني في ظل
حكم الكرملين ، كما قال إنها مسألة
وقت فقط قبل أن يتم تحرير جميع أراضيها المحتلة ،
وتنضم إلينا كلير سيباستيان مراسلة CNN الآن من لندن مع المزيد
كلير ، ما هي الرسالة التي يحاول بوتين
إرسالها هنا
ترحيبًا ، فهذه الزيارات لم يعلن عنها مسبقًا
وتأتي بعد يوم واحد فقط من
إصدار
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية مذكرة توقيف ضد
فلاديمير بوتين نفسه مع
شبه جزيرة القرم ، وقد تم تصميمها لتتزامن مع
ذكرى ذلك الضم.
الذكرى التاسعة لكن زيارة ماروبا
التي نعتقد أنها المرة الأولى التي
يزور فيها الأراضي التي تحتلها روسيا في
أوكرانيا منذ بدء الغزو والتي
يمكن قراءتها على أنها تحدٍ
منخفض الخطورة ، وتجدر الإشارة إلى
أن هذا احتلال روسي أه
المنطقة ولكنك ما زلت تعرف أنه
من المحتمل أن يوجه نظره إلى
مذكرة التوقيف هذه فيما يتعلق بالشعب الروسي وكيف يتم
تقديم ذلك لهم ،
أعني أنه رآه خلف السيارة التي
يقودونها من مطار
ماريبل أه باتجاه ماريوبال ، نعتقد
أن  آخر مرة رأيناه خلف السيارة
كان يقودها خلف عجلة قيادة سيارة
كانت تقود شاحنة عبر
جسر كيرش إلى شبه جزيرة القرم الذي تم تفجيره في
الخريف ثم أعادت
روسيا بناؤه جزئيًا ، وهو مصمم لإظهار
التحكم في المشروع وهو المسؤول  أعتقد أن
هناك أيضًا عنصرًا لتطبيع
هذه الأراضي كجزء من روسيا ، فهو موجود
هناك مع نائب رئيس الوزراء
لمناقشة إعادة بناء
المباني السكنية حتى أنهم يزورون
الفيلهارمونيك الذي ليس بعيدًا عن
مسرح الدراما الذي قصفته روسيا
منذ عام تقريبًا إلى  في يوم
يُعتقد أنه ربما يكون أكبر
حدث ضحى جماعي في هذه الحرب ، حيث
تراه جالسًا في الفيلهارمونيك ،
أشار نائب رئيس الوزراء أيضًا إلى أنهم
يتوقعون تقديم عرض في
المسرح الدرامي في أقرب وقت ممكن في أبريل / نيسان
جهود إعادة الإعمار هنا بالطبع
قاموا بهذا النوع من التطبيع مع
شبه جزيرة القرم منذ عام 2014 ، لذا أعتقد أن هذه هي
الرسالة التي يحاولون إيصالها ولكن
بالطبع أوكرانيا توضح تمامًا
أن أي نوع من المفاوضات مع
روسيا يجب أن  تتضمن عودة
هذه الأراضي ، وهو شيء من
الواضح أن روسيا تخلعه عن الطاولة ،
ولا أعلم وهو يندفع بوتين يوم السبت وهو يتجول في
الشوارع التي ساعد في تدميرها في
بلد لا يزال مترسخًا بعمق في الحرب ،
ما نوع الرسالة التي ترسل
كليهما إلى قواته  والأوكرانيين الذين
يحاولون إرسال رسالة إلى باولا ولكنه
يواجه بعض الصعوبات الحقيقية في فعل
ذلك كما ترون في هذه الصور كان
يمر عبر اه
المبنى السكني الذي أعيد بناؤه نوعًا
ما كقرية بوتيمكين وأنا لا أستخدم
ذلك  المصطلح غير محكم في مدينة ماري
أوبال الآن تذكر كما قلت للتو ، لقد
دمرت تلك المدينة تمامًا بسبب
قصفه للشقق المدنية والمستشفيات
والمدارس ، والآن
سيعود لإلقاء نظرة حوله وهي
صورة فوتوغرافية كما تراه  في هذا في هذا
الفيلم الآن في وسط
مبنى سكني حيث يحاول
نقل بعض المواطنين الأوكرانيين أه ،
فإنه يرسل إشارة أيضًا
لأنه لا يزال بعيدًا جدًا عن الغرب
خلف خطوط العدو ، إنه في
المقاطعة أوبلست دونتس
يسيطر الروس على تلك
المقاطعة في الوقت الحالي ، لكنني أعتقد أننا سنرى
في الأشهر المقبلة
أنها ستكون منطقة مستهدفة للهجوم
المضاد الأوكراني لاستعادة
أراضيهم السيادية